[Music]
it's been a crazy week in america let's
find out what happened
after receiving criticism for saying
that president biden's infrastructure
plan
would create 19 million jobs
transportation secretary pete
butterjudge this week
walked back the claim and said he quote
should have been more precise
though it's weird that a guy named
buddha judge forgot to dot some eyes and
cross some t's
lots of letters
congress on monday returned from a
two-week recess
and so did i the difference is now that
i'm back i'm actually going to do my job
according to a new poll 46 percent of
adults would support
the actor dwayne the rock johnson
running for president
said the other 54 percent
wow
four teenage girls were charged with
arson last week after they allegedly
started a fire because they were bored
even worse they all had the same
emergency contact
wait is that a contact lens that makes
no sense with this joke
sorry sorry it's frank in the control
room uh that's our bed that was the
wrong graphic uh we got the right one
now
okay great let's just take that from the
top again
four teenage girls were charged with
arson last week after they allegedly
started a fire
because they were bored even worse they
all had the same emergency contact
okay yep that's clearly not it either
the joke doesn't have anything to do
with the movie contact
well you're right wrong graphic again uh
just just run it one more time
okay even worse they all had the same
emergency contact
that's my mom she's my emergency contact
what the hell is going on in the control
room sorry it's leon's birthday we're
all a little distracted
who's leon yeah you wouldn't know he
doesn't work here just
find the right freaking picture great
geez
sorry we got it now four teenage girls
were charged with arson last week
after they allegedly started a fire
because they were bored
even worse they all had the same
emergency contact
there it is yes thank you actor will
smith announced this week that he will
no longer film his upcoming movie in
georgia
after the state passed a voter
suppression law his exact words upon
hearing about that law were no no
no no no no no no no no
[Laughter]
you're welcome well i'd like to remind
you you came here
i'm not in your house you're over here
yeah and in this house
we get jiggy
oh we are your parents
and seltzer brand whiteclaw recently
announced that it would launch a new
product that contains more alcohol
it comes in the flavors cranberry blood
orange and
help me i'm depressed according to
new satellite data a glacier in alaska
has recently moved as much as 90 feet
per day
okay glacier get your steps in girl
glacier you better get it oh i'm getting
it get it
satanic
[Laughter]
and that's how it happened that was live
footage of the titanic
and finally the makers of miller lite
are now
offering bar scented candles or if you
can't get your hands on one
just get a regular candle and pee on it
and that was the monologue tarik
did you like the monologue yes those
were my favorite eight jokes i heard all
week
all right now the monologue did a good
job covering a lot of news stories but
there's one more i'd like to talk about
in order to promote vaccinations
krispy kreme announced that they'll be
giving out a free donut to anyone who
shows their full vaccine card for the
rest of the year
still not going to take it well why not
i don't trust it
my uncle got the vaccine he still died
of kovid
no i got hit by a car but still well
that is too bad because
i was inspired by krispy kreme using
their platform to encourage
people to get the vaccine so i was going
to do the same thing today
what do you mean i came up with an
incentive that i thought might motivate
reluctant people to get vaccinated sorry
dude
there is nothing that will motivate me
to get that vex
well that's too bad because for today
only if you can show me a card proving
that you've received the coronavirus
vaccine you'll be entered into a raffle
where one special winner will receive a
very unique prize
a pass that allows its owner to say the
n-word
one time
[Music]
it's happening my dreams are finally
coming true out of my way i gotta get
the next scene
i should have never hired that guy i
knew he didn't look right
okay tarek now i haven't checked in with
you yet
how was your week good how was your week
shitty
um i bet i can guess why yeah it's
partly the derek chauvin trial and
partly that cop who pepper sprayed that
soldier in virginia and the piece of
[ __ ] minnesota officer who shot that 20
year old and
the 13 year old victim of police
violence in chicago
you see those videos of police officers
deciding whether or not to commit murder
and against you
yes it does and like you super hate
those shitty cops you do but
all that hate and anger has an effect on
you so instead of just the horrible
thing
you have to deal with the horrible thing
its effect on your safety
and the anger it gives you look all i'm
saying is
i had a week
[Music]
this was the week i hit the wall
problems couldn't solve them all i
failed and failed
this was the week i fell behind kind of
sort of lost my mind worked at the pace
of a snail sounds terrible
had a bad day on monday and tuesday and
wednesday
on thursday i cried i had a bunch of bad
feelings and i just couldn't keep them
all inside
this week was the week i hit the wall
oh yeah i've been there you've been
there you bet
tell me about it i hit a wall
last week mine's in a deep peak and i
lost my natural mind
i heard a wall that's right stayed awake
day and night left my common sense far
behind
oh no oh yeah had a bad day on monday
and tuesday and wednesday
so i stayed in bed and when i woke up it
was friday couldn't get
that through my head
this week was the week i hit the wall
tell me about it and you never know
what's gonna set you off either
i noticed that i watched my local news
and i almost cried i saw a cute little
dog i got
missed the eye the weather got a little
warm i remember the resilience of the
seasons and that made me cry
it happens to everyone and it's no fun
but
you'll make it to the other side but
until you do
afraid to say it's true you may be in
for quite a ride
it's okay we're all taking turns just
hitting the wall
next week will be great it's okay you
just hit a little wall
just hit a little wall you're not weak
it's just the week you hit the wall
we wrote that before last night i have
my own youtube channel now
yay be sure to subscribe for a lot of
show clips and a lot of digital
exclusives
and a lot of this
you